je m'appelle luc pétillot j'ai 56 ans et
je suis sait lire ni soeur ça fait 36
ans que je suis dans le métier
j'ai commencé chez les compagnons du
devoir
j'ai bon comme on dit ont pour langue et
en france chez plusieurs patrons ça fait
25 ans que la réunion et ça fait
d'une quinzaine d'années que je
travaille dans
dans le cas
je le rejoins tienne j'ai 25 ans je suis
j'ai commencé dans le métier de capitaux
mais il ya trois ans tant que ces apps
est conservé et je conduis ma formation
avec mon collègue
le métier c'est-à-dire op tous qui
répare son siège on va démonter le siège
pour refaire déjà les gabarits voir si
l'annoncé paris mais parce que des fois
on a les mousses qui sont complètement
abîmé et donc notre première phase c'est
refaire la mousse préparer la mousse la
mousse réparer nous allons faire les
gabarits dégâts briefé nous allons faire
de la coupe c'est à dire la coupe de la
moquette qui est au dos les tissus et
quand nous avons fini ceci nous passons
en couture le remontage et après le
siège remonter dans
dans leur demande quoi comme qualité
porteurs de chansons d'hier et de la
patience il faut pas mal réfléchi à part
un moment imaginé le siège d amener
aussi ça ça peut ça peut aider imaginez
le travail terminé donc là vous
travaillez à deux c'est ça se passe il
ya vraiment un échange de de
connaissance il ya à huy mentionner tous
les deux sébastien problème on va voir
la tâche à chaque fois plus c'est plus
moi qui va le voir comme il a plus
d'expérience ça être des fois il donne
deux trois petites techniques c'est
chaque personne à cette technique dans
le métier et battre chaque personne ça
change quoi chacun a ses techniques et
puis après au fur et à mesure du temps
chacun fait les siennes
j'essaie quand même agréable d'avoir un
quart propre bien bien entretenu donc
voilà je pense qu'on veut prendre je
suis assez satisfait quand même des
retombées qu'on a envers la direction
qui nous disent qu'on a des cars propre
et ça fait quand même pas mal de temps
quand même que je travaille dans
l'entreprise et ça fait plaisir
voilà c'est agréable de voir qu'on peut
partir d'une pièce qui est mondial et
abîmée puis retour offert est reparti
assure gratuitement g9 la prison mais
dans le but de plaisir à regarder
un mot pour les pinceaux vieux les
gentils panne de bus arrêtés des gradins